hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control AC dot
l2-3.1.17 protect wireless access using
authentication and encryption
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist sp-800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmfc control ac.l2-3.1.17
elementop whatever protect wireless
access using authentication and
encryption so with this control there's
really a need to clarify that the
wireless protection and use has to be
password protected or some other method
of authentication in place and it needs
to be encrypted remember when it comes
to cui if encryption is the only way to
protect it in transit and it's for
wireless networks then you
well you know let's check out how the
assessor are what let's check out what
the assessors are looking for and how to
make them happy
talking about protecting wireless access
using authentication encryption uh
there's two points in which an assessor
will want to hit point number one
determine if wireless access to the
system is protected uh using
authentication so in other words are you
actually having someone authenticate
before they use the wireless network
right they can't get on without that uh
so we're going to give a sample answer
of authentication is required before
access is actually granted to wireless
networks right so I.E you've got a
secure token or a designated device that
you got from someone in management or
maybe just a wireless password but some
kind of authentication has to happen in
order for you to get access on that
wireless network now assessing Point
number two determine if wireless access
to the system is protected using
encryption so now we get told we can
have wireless open wireless networks
they have to be encrypted so we would
probably say something to the extent of
describing like what kind of wireless
security they have so it's not like
wireless access utilizes WPA2 encryption
and then again during an assessment you
know you're going to have to show so
your actual settings on your wireless
access points so definitely be prepared
for that so hey an on-call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and I
don't know about you but if the weather
looks good out there to me we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins and maybe we don't
make it suck so much now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance nerves
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
thank you
[Music]